Israel es uno de los países más
controvertidos del mundo y lo cierto es
que resulta muy difícil hablar de él
sin referirnos a guerras, religión o
conflictos políticos varios. Sin embargo,
con este vídeo en VisualPolitik
queremos verter luz sobre otra cara de
este país. Porque amigos en las últimas
décadas Israel se ha convertido en una
de las mayores potencias tecnológicas
del mundo y esto es algo que resulta
sorprendente.
Hablamos de un país pequeño que con
apenas ocho millones de habitantes una
población inferior a la de Andalucía y
una superficie equiparable a la de la
Comunidad Valenciana en España o el
Salvador en Latinoamérica cuenta
atentos con más de 4.000 compañías
tecnológicas y 80 de las 500 mayores
empresas del mundo tienen aquí filiales
orientadas a la investigación y la
innovación.
De hecho, Tel Aviv es tras Silicon Valley
el polo de tecnología e innovación más
importante del mundo y aunque parezca
mentira por su reducido tamaño, Israel
es el tercer país sólo tras Estados
Unidos y China con más empresas
cotizando en el Nasdaq, la bolsa de valores
de Estados Unidos orientada
preferentemente a compañías
tecnológicas.
Hablamos de que Israel tiene más
empresas cotizando en este mercado que
la suma de España, Italia, Francia
Alemania y Holanda.
¡Casi nada! Pero, ¿queréis ejemplos
concretos? Pues bien, en Israel se está
desarrollando gran parte del hardware
del próximo iPhone 8, muchas de las
características de Google son 'made in
Israel' e Intel
el líder mundial de microchips le debe
gran parte de su éxito a las
innovaciones de su filial hebrea, la cual
por cierto con más de 11.000
trabajadores es una de las mayores
empresas de todo el país. Bueno e
incluso Microsoft ha llegado a
considerarse como una empresa semi
israelí.
Paypal, IBM, Cisco, Amazon, Facebook son
muchas las empresas que utilizamos cada
día cuya tecnología depende en gran
medida de este país volcado con la I+D+i
Y es que este sector supone ya, ¡ojo! Más
del 12% del PIB nacional, más que
el turismo en España, por ejemplo, y la
mitad de todas las exportaciones
Y os preguntaréis, ¿cómo ha conseguido Israel
semejante éxito? Porque este es el punto
más importante.
Habitualmente se alude a factores
culturales pero hoy queremos prestar
atención a tres políticas claves en
todo este proceso.
YOZMA
En Israel la década de los 80 se
recuerda como una década horrible,
especialmente desde el punto de vista
económico.
por aquel entonces el país atravesaba
una dura crisis, la inflación entre 1980
y 1985 superó el cien por cien cada
año los déficit públicos y la deuda
eran prácticamente inasumibles y la
economía en general estaba maniatada
por una excesiva intervención del
Estado. En buena medida aquel Israel
era muy dependiente de la ayuda llegada
de diferentes partes del mundo y aunque
la situación comenzó a estabilizarse a
finales de los 80
justo en ese momento comenzó la masiva
llegada de población judía procedente
de los diferentes territorios de la
Unión Soviética. En poco tiempo
llegarían al país
800.000 personas. ¡Ojo con la
magnitud! Porque fue algo así como si en
apenas una década llegarán a españa 9
millones de inmigrantes y en este
contexto la pregunta era clara: ¿cómo
generar empleos para tantas personas con
una economía deprimida?
Sin duda a israel le tocaba cambiar.
"Nos curamos como equipo o nos desmoronamos".
En un primer momento el gobierno apostó
por explotar la cualificación de los
recién llegados promoviendo la
creación de empresas con subsidios e
incubadoras que apoyasen la labor de los
emprendedores pero pronto se dieron
cuenta de que este sistema aunque
conseguía desarrollar ideas, apenas
lograba crear empresas prósperas. Los
inmigrantes no tenían experiencia en la
gestión carecían de redes comerciales
y apenas conseguían financiación
al fin y al cabo, ¿quién iba a invertir su dinero
en un lugar tan convulso como Israel? Y
aquí fue donde el gobierno de Israel se
dio cuenta de que la clave estaba en
apostar por atraer el capital riesgo
internacional es decir atraer a aquellos
fondos orientados a financiar nuevas
ideas y nuevas empresas.
- "Desen ustedes
cuenta que aquellas sociedades más
avanzadas, aquellos países más
avanzados, tienen unos capitales riesgo muy
bien muy fuertes"
Para lograrlo crearon
el ingenioso y exitoso programa Yozma, con
él el gobierno creó diez fondos de
capital riesgo y puso 100 millones de
dólares sobre la mesa bajo las
siguientes condiciones: cada fondo que
recaudara 12 millones de inversores
privados recibiría a cambio 8 millones
de inversión pública. El gobierno se
quedaba con el 40% de la
propiedad pero en caso de que los
proyectos tuviesen éxito los inversores
podían hacerse con la
participación del gobierno simplemente
devolviéndole la aportación inicial
más unos pocos intereses.
"Después del éxito del yozma todo fue
como una bola de nieve más fondos
vieron el éxito y decidieron venir a
Israel y el fondo que creamos captó
más dinero.
Todo empezó con 200 millones y en 10
años ya habíamos conseguido traer
15.000 para invertir en compañías
locales".
Es decir amigos, si las cosas
iban bien el beneficio recaía
fundamentalmente en los inversores y si las
cosas marchaban mal el gobierno
compartía la pérdida. Esto puede
parecer injusto pero lo cierto es que la
inversión pública requerida era
relativamente pequeña y además el
gobierno esperaba recuperar cualquier
pérdida con los impuestos que generase
esta nueva industria.
Desde entonces prácticamente todos los
programas públicos en Israel han
seguido este esquema y lo cierto es que
los resultados no pudieron ser mejores:
el dinero internacional comenzó a
llegar; hubo financiación para prácticamente
cualquier idea y tan sólo en
los primeros ocho años el número de
fondos pasó de 20 a 513. El resultado es
que hoy Israel tiene uno de los mayores
ecosistemas de capital emprendedor del
mundo y de acuerdo a los últimos datos
de la OCDE, la inversión disponible
para lanzar nuevas empresas supera, ¡ojo!
Los 150 dólares por persona y año. En
España, por comparar, esta cifra se
reduce a poco más de 3,5 dólares, ¡40
veces menos!
La clave en todo este proceso es que
los fondos de capital riesgo no sólo
aportan dinero también experiencia,
gestión y contactos vitales.
Israel es el país del mundo más abierto a
la inmigración uno de cada tres
ciudadanos ha nacido en el extranjero
nueve de cada diez son, bien inmigrantes, bien
hijos o nietos de inmigrantes. Un
caudal de inmigración impresionante que
explica que su población haya pasado de
apenas 800 mil habitantes en 1948, cuando
se funda el país, a más de 8 millones
hoy en día. Es decir, en poco más de 60
años se ha multiplicado por diez.
"En esta última ronda de inmigrantes
aproximadamente 50 judíos franceses
llegaron al aeropuerto de Ben Gurion en
Tel Aviv.
De hecho, Israel es la única nación de
la historia que recoge explícitamente
en sus documentos fundacionales la
necesidad de tener una política de
inmigración abierta.
Así, conforme a la ley de retorno
aprobada en 1950 y aún hoy en vigor
"todo judío
independientemente de donde haya nacido
tiene derecho a trasladarse a Israel".
Y éste no es un factor baladí,
la inmigración ha contribuido tanto al
milagro económico como cualquier otro
factor.
Y es que a pesar de lo que dicen muchos
populistas, las naciones más ricas tienden
a ser aquellas que tienen más
inmigrantes, entre otros factores porque
éstos suelen tener tasas de
emprendimiento superiores a las de la
población local y porque además
impulsan el comercio internacional,
especialmente con sus países de origen.
¡Por cierto!
Próximamente le dedicaremos un vídeo
a esta cuestión
La apuesta de Israel por contar con un
sistema de educación de altísima
calidad forma parte casi de su
identidad. Ya en 1918, 30 años antes de
la propia fundación del Estado de
Israel,
los colonos judíos fundaron la
Universidad Hebrea de Jerusalén y hoy
el país cuenta con una de las mayores
tasas de población con estudios
universitarios del mundo. Y sobre todo,
hay que decirlo, ha hecho muy bien los
deberes en cuanto a la integración
entre empresa y universidad.
La financiación de las universidades de
Israel a diferencia de lo que ocurre por
ejemplo en España depende en gran
medida de los proyectos financiados por
empresas privadas con lo que existen
incentivos evidentes a colaborar con
ellas. Y además logran la mayor ratio de
creación de empresas de toda la OCDE.
"La transferencia de conocimiento es
imprescindible,
esto nos está llevando al mundo
universitario en el mundo profesional a
colaborar cada vez de manera más
estrecha y yo creo que eso es muy bueno".
En Israel
las ideas se transforman en empresas y
en empleos. Bien todos estos elementos junto
a factores culturales como la Jutzpah,
la tendencia a cuestionar todo que es
clave en la cultura judía,
el ejército y la mili obligatoria que
favorecen la movilidad social poniendo
en contacto directo a jóvenes de
diferentes estratos sociales y
formaciones; o las reforma de Netanyahu en
2003 de las que ya hablaremos han
alimentado el éxito de Israel, un país
que desde 1980 ha más que duplicado su
población ha multiplicado por cuatro el
número de empleos y ha crecido a una
tasa media del 4% anual, de tal forma que
hoy su PIB per cápita con 36.000
dólares es superior por ejemplo al de
España o Italia.
Bueno, ¿tú qué opinas? ¿Se consolidará
Israel como la mayor potencia
tecnológica del mundo? ¿Es replicable
su modelo a otros países? Espero
que te haya resultado interesante este
video ya sabes que podrás encontrar
muchos más en nuestro canal de YouTube
y también los próximos domingos en
lavanguardia.com
¡Un saludo y hasta la
próxima, amigos!